yeah how old were you when you started
uh getting recognized for skating
um how did you start it's the first time
anyone actually recognized me
out in the
wild arcade
i was at an arcade i was 14. from in san
diego san diego i was 14. how old are
you uh i am 53. 53. yeah
so you were tall for your age
i
yeah i didn't get tall until i was about
17. i'm talking about now you are tall
am i supposed to shrink i don't know i
don't know
you're tony hawk and i was like how do
you know that you talked about how old
were you when you got your first
skateboard
14.
oh no first skateboard i was 10.
and were your parents into skating did
your dad's no my brother my older
brother was a surfer uh and my dad was
in the military he was the navy he ended
up stationed in san diego that's how we
ended up there my brother was a surfer
and then during the sort of 70s dog town
and z boys era that's what i saw that
documentary at dogtown and right and
zebra so he was that age and he skated
because it was an extension of surfing
right and then one day i just picked up
one of his boards and started using his
transportation
and so you're so you're that's how
you're getting around town
and then what is getting to school yeah
and what is the next step to becoming
like
then do you compete with other kids that
are doing that no the next step was that
uh my friend was going to the local
skate park and that was a big deal
and the i think the age limit for the
skate park was 10
and so i just turned 10 and i went with
him and i literally saw people
flying out of swimming pools and it was
like i had this epiphany i just i want
to do that i don't know whatever that is
i want to learn how to do it because it
looks like so dog town and z boys
already existed already existed yeah it
was it was it was yeah yeah
and they were talking about like 78 79
and then so you see these people jumping
out or dropping in the pools yeah and
did you did you have equipment to do
that did you have no i was wearing
volleyball pads that's what i'm thinking
volleyball knee pads um my skateboard
was from a swap meet
um like on a clearance bin and right uh
i did but i just knew that i wan i i
wanted to figure out how to do it like i
wanted to
take every step to get there was it
wasn't that i was willing to throw a
caution in the wind but i definitely
wasn't afraid to get hurt
to learn how to do these things and and
did you befriend the people that were
already there how did you no i just i
just uh
i just figured out how to get to the
skate park as often as possible so you
got to so you're at the skate park you
have the shitty equipment yeah you're 10
years old yeah and what is the next step
do you you see uh i went i convinced my
dad to get me a better skateboard
um he got me a better skateboard at the
swap meet
but but more professional looking
and then
my brother was i believe he was in
college at the time
and he would drive he was in college in
santa barbara he would drive down from
santa barbara and take me to the skate
park once a week but like even just
dropping in
am i using the right terminology yeah
like i wouldn't know how to like if i
saw a pool i would be afraid like the
fir
going along the sidewalk and making it
your transportation as opposed to
trying to do something
they had they had uh different skill
level areas so they had a beginner's
area they had an intermediate area and
so i kind of worked my way up and then
the the advanced area were the deep
pools but they had shallower pools
in the other areas so i figured out how
to ride those had to drop in on those
how to sometimes fly out of them and
then eventually made my way over to the
bigger pools and then once i started to
get more confidence more skills i
started to reach the top of the pools
and i me i remember vividly the first
time i ever actually got out of the pool
and it was like that was it i was never
i was never stopping how old were you
when you first got up i was i think i
was 11 or 12.
was that like the turning point from
bony [ __ ] to tony hawk like no i'm
serious
that name followed me actually i think
that name was more created during my
skate years we're gonna use that name on
the the title of this i don't even need
the name though full circle i don't even
mean the name though i mean like cool
acceptance with like other kids at
school and all that kind of stuff
skateboarding was the furthest thing
from cool you could do in
1980-81
because it had already come and gone
well let's let's stay where you are
you're in 1978 you're now you fly out of
the pool
and you go i love this and i want to be
there every minute
um
so do uh
when you're starting did you ever have a
big injury at that time i would imagine
that you get banged up a lot uh yeah
within my first six months of skating i
had a concussion and knocked my front
teeth out
that was when your parents never said
don't do this um
no they they were concerned um but i was
the youngest of of four siblings and
they had kind of been through so much
with my older with with my older sisters
my older brother and it was just kind of
like whatever kept me busy just let me
go because i was so
i i was
remember the 70s you were diagnosed as
hyperactive right i was hyperactive
doesn't mean they're going to do
anything for you but i was just always
going going going so it was just like
whatever keeps him busy and out of the
house and happy let him do that and so
when i did get hurt they were obviously
concerned but
it was the 70s
and getting your a concussion and
getting your teeth knocked out there was
never any trepidation of going back
tomorrow and jumping on the board no not
for me
so now you get hurt and you're
you're getting in and out of the board
is your brother also skating alongside
that's when he started to kind of pull
away from it
um because he was starting to he was
graduating he got a job and it like i
said it was just more it was considered
a kid's fad so i was still a kid okay so
at from where is the turning point for
when you're just having fun in a park
where you say
were you getting recognition or
sponsorship i don't know what the next
what is the next step um it was a very
small community at that point and there
were only a couple parks still open
all over in the u.s or across the world
and so
uh there were some competitions they
they would do
they they created skate park teams and
so i was the on the skatepark team in my
age division and then we would go to
different skate parks and compete you
try to you tried to gain points for your
park
and then within that first year
i got an actual skateboard sponsor um
that which meant that you just got a
free skateboard
they didn't pay you anything no there
was no money okay so now you got a free
skateboard not free skateboard i was
actually sponsored by dog town that was
my first sponsor really yeah but it was
right at the tail end of their success
and and little did i know they were
going out of business when they chose to
sponsor me and at some point i wasn't
getting skateboards from them no one was
calling me and then stacy peralta who is
the founder of pal peralta the bones
brigade team
he called me um i remember because i was
i was home in san diego and my mom's
like it's long distance long distance
stacey bralton
he called me he said hey tony i heard
dogtown went out of business
i didn't know i guess that's why i'm not
getting skateboards right and then he
said i'd like you to come up here to la
and talk about writing for paul peralta
and and that's what you did yes
how old were you yeah uh i was 12.
and
your mom and dad were okay with having
you leave town and my brother brought me
my brother was still very supportive so
he he drove me to marina del rey which
is the sort of epicenter of where the
doghound z boys skated with venice right
yeah i mean venice but but but uh marina
del rey skate park was right under the
90 freeway right it was like that's
still there guys no no no but that's
where all those guys would skate so that
was the that was sort of the most
hardcore epicenter of skateboarding at
the time so i came to marina and met at
men's stacey
and he said hey you know we'd like to
sponsor you on the buns brigade and to
me
i was a little
i was a little hesitant because that was
the ultimate team
and i was still
i was bony [ __ ] i was still that
that skinny kid that was made fun of for
the most part for my style people did
not like my style at all is your style
considered different well it was more
and at that time it was more focused on
tricks and it wasn't about it wasn't
about
flow and speed and power and aerials it
was more like i was doing these little
spins and stuff with my skateboard like
i was twirling a baton so they they said
i was doing circus tricks
but the fact that i had validation from
stacy peralta went a long way
so once i got on the bones brigade
and started to do well in different
events then that that narrative changed
well you changed the style right or what
people looked for in the whole sport um
there was a technique that i developed
that that i was made fun of originally
that now is the standard way that people
do aerials so but when you were young
and they were making fun of this style
did you
i'm fascinated young kid but it sucked
but i would think that i would be as a
young person going you know what they're
making fun of me i'm going to try to do
it the way they're doing it you didn't
change i didn't have the strength to do
that i was so skinny that that i was
doing it out of desperation
because i was doing this technique where
when when the like the dog town crew and
the the people of the late 70s when they
would do aerials out of pools they would
reach down and grab their board before
they got to the top right and then just
kind of muscle it into the air and it
was just more like a hop
and what i developed is is doing an
ollie near the top and then launching
myself into the air and then grabbing my
board at the apex and the reason i did
that is because i didn't have the
strength to muscle myself into the air
so i had to launch
and that became this the way to do it
because you could get way more higher
that way you don't you don't kill your
speed by reaching down for your board
before you leave the the pool and this
is also the predecessor too do you uh
snowboard yeah
and and skateboard would be the
predecessor there wasn't snowboarding at
the time no so and all those tricks and
all those the ollies and all that is the
same terminology that they're using in
uh yeah snowboarding has kind of taken
on a life of its own because now it's a
lot of gymnastics type of moves and
they're not just flips and things and
you don't do that in skateboarding um we
do a bit of that but it but it's just
different it's just a different it's a
different plane and and you're attached
to the board so the ollie is sort of
is redundant
and and and i find this fascinating that
you started doing this
as a kid for transportation you created
a style and now this style is uh what is
looked upon as professionally i mean i
watched it in the olympics for the first
time right yeah yeah and such i mean
you're still a young guy i mean in your
life from 10 years old to 53 you're
watching something that you did your
brother takes you to a park i go oh
that's kind of cool and because you did
it because i believe that you are a
leader of this sport not only are you
well known don't no thank you you i had
a skateboard when i was a little kid but
nothing i did was going to lead to
changing the world i'm older than you
i'm a decade older than you and and i
had it i had a wooden
shitty wooden flat i think i had a two
by four with some wheels from uh from
roller skates yeah yeah that's that's it
was the same way
that's what i had them and that's how i
used to go to my friend's house when i
didn't want to take my bike but you
tried this thing out and now the world
is watching it on look who's here do you
know this guy oh
hey do you know do you know theo vaughn
i do i just got to i had the honor of
doing a show recently wait is this real
you're just coming
[Laughter]
before you measure this why don't you
measure bone and pot
measure boney [ __ ]
measuring
are you buying carpet for me
[Music]
you